welcome to this video I actually get it
25-minute game hi okay I are you sad I
was already giving up on that thinking
that I don't get on and I was trying to
play a five minute game and now I get a
25-minute game yeah okay against hmm how
I yahoo you or something is this a let's
check 25 it's not in there huh do I
actually have to what a waste I wonder
if this is the provisional rating or not
1996 is really high it's probably
provisioned by one hmm ok so do we get
here 93 or 93 move I usually play the
NIMS Oh with 93 or allow the name zone
but check let's do something else always
playing my line at the bogo mm ok and
let's go watch a specialty 237 yeah this
is a good line of course let's see
and school 93 m I can also play g3 but
it's not a huge difference in quality
between those b6 mmm well it's a bit
more common to play d6 base set up and
in the Boko but ok when black certainly
can play like this is nothing wrong with
it just not as frequently seen Queen day
for knight c6 set ready playable check
check check no it isn't right check 96
95 and I'm just winning right what is
there at the point there
yeah 95 and that's the end of it
threatening a ton on c6 and D is six
Bishop c6 will win apiece ultimately
yeah just like that there's a quick end
to that game guys will be have one of
those days where I upload to rapid games
nadie six was really weird I mean you
can't play with g6 but you probably have
really should castle first
I went back everything with interest now
d5 Bishop c6 if you move the King I'll
take the bishop on b7 and d is six
Bishop c6 Bishop c6 Quincy six yeah that
that you can do that but there's no
difference i can even take what the
bishop or stairs something wait wait
wait wait wait wait if i take the three
capture there's probably g5g five nights
is 627 so maybe maybe I actually should
play Bishop c6 and disposition check
yeah not bishops III yep then d 5 would
be kind of tricky yeah and now I can
just recapture him and this is just just
a piece d takes a five I can even go
Bishop before winning the Queen yep and
that's the Queen
Bishop takes b7 was slack everything was
a piece but yeah it was his 16th 50
minutes still a provisional rating okay
that was really quick and not that much
to say d 6 is just giving the game away
feat castles I castle and if he likes
you can go d 6 now and this is totally
fine of course there's no check and I
don't know what I'm playing here Quincy
to rook see one typical Queens Indian
Babu Indian type of position d6 check
yeah now 95 is the end of it and this
was a nice little point if I recapture
he actually has a d5 and this is a bit
awkward for me because this is not that
great it's funny that the engine still
says after Luke see one that I'm
completely winning um why
not soon okay probably queen bee 65 or
something no cheeks and this yeah okay
the Lucas this is far too much pressure
okay okay but this is winning yet so I'm
okay and yeah this is the queen but well
there is no real difference here orbit
the Queen nuts and so it's just a piece
for absolutely nothing so that it was a
very short 25-minute game but well i'll
upload a second one to to keep that
short video company thanks for watching